buonasera
siccome sono lento ha fatto metà del mio
pc lui così si trova in una sera sono
ferdinando acerbi e sono qua per
parlarvi di social innovation
premesso che sostanzialmente non so di
che cosa si tratti
cominciamo a conoscerci noi così almeno
scartiamo la parte sociale infieriamo
più tardi la la parte di innovazione
come giustamente vi ha raccontato carlo
sono un ex atleta che a un certo punto
la sua vita avuto un incidente che
sicuramente gli ha precluso alcune
opportunità ma il miele aperte altre
quali quella per esempio di essere quasi
a creare con voi oggi pomeriggio e
adesso che ho fatto la mia presentazione
vediamo un po fra di voi
vediamo c'è qualcun altro in sala che ha
una disabilità per caso no bene che
quanti siamo due giusto perfetto allora
ci stiamo dicendo in poche parole se mi
permettete un sillogismo non tanto
politicamente corretto che a parte noi
due onesti portatori di andicap voi
tutti quanti qua in sala correte almeno
forte tanto quanto volte giusto nella
passata di questa sì allora non ridiamo
tanto perché adesso magicamente ci
troviamo catapultati in una savana dove
c'è un leone che ci corre dietro
evidentemente stante così la situazione
noi due onesti moriamo per prima e poi a
seguire ognuno di voi a seconda del
vostro grado di
capacità residua giusto se ci
immaginiamo però che qualcuno ci avesse
avvisato prima guarda se vai al ted
certo punto viene catapultato la c'è un
leone ti mangia non lo so io
personalmente mi sarei in formato per lo
meno sulle abitudini alimentari del
leone a che ora mangia il territorio c'è
un albero basso che è accessibile non lo
so credo che voi aveste fatto lo stesso
e credo che ora invece di essere qua ad
ascoltare noi saremo tutti insieme
cercando di organizzarsi in maniera di
creare da creare poter creare una
struttura tale che possa essere utile
nella nostra della nostra dell'avventura
che andremo ad affrontare insieme
struttura che io mi immagino con noi due
più deboli al centro e viceversa a noi a
scalare tutti voi fino ad arrivare a chi
veramente corre come bolt che si occupa
di caccia re leone nella sua nella sua
foresta abbiamo qua in questo momento
creato ho fatto la pittura la fotografia
di quella che è una società basic è
abbassata sul welfare giusto i deboli al
centro e chi più capace di loro che si
adopera per aiutarli ora mettiamoci
dentro un pò di innovazione finalmente
immaginiamoci che dal blu un qualche
babbo natale arriva arrivi nel nostro
campeggio e mette in mano di ognuno di
noi uno smartphone mi seguite se vi dico
di immaginarvi quanta potenza di tiro
avremmo acquisito con una semplice con
un semplice strumento in mano potremo
condividere il territorio potremo dirci
dove leone potremo sapere dove sono le
nostre truppe
potremmo muoverci come un sol uomo
grazie all'intelligenza di tutti è stata
questa l'intuizione che mi ha portato a
diventare digitalmente abile ossia a
cercare soluzioni digitali
problemi reali problemi che mi vengono
evidenziati dalla base e problemi che
non sono il macro problema percepibile
da tutti voi di una disabilità ma sono
problemi che stanno al di sotto di un
livello che fa sì che se non siamo noi
disabili
a evidenziarlo molto difficilmente può
essere percepito o riso o risolto da una
persona normale ci siamo a questo punto
cosa succede succede invece che quello
che era stato pensato per una nicchia
molto ristretta di persone per un gruppo
di persone in realtà si è dimostrato
essere fruibile poi da tutti con piccoli
accorgimenti a dimostrazione del fatto
che se di giulia re una catena e parti
dall anello più debole
tutto il resto della catena diventa
automaticamente più forte
le quali porto un attimino ancora
pensare pensiamo che tutti quanti noi
chi prima chi dopo non lo so siamo
vittime di questo leone tutti quanti
invecchiamo spero e tutti quanti
prima o poi avremmo bisogno di un
ausilio
oggi per me il digitale è un ausilio
come non sono i miei occhiali come
l'aveva il mio bastone e quello che mi
permette di comunicare e quello che mi
snellisce le giornate quello che mi
risolve parte della burocrazia che sta
attorno alla mia disabilità è un'arma e
allora dico
usiamola quest'arma perché siamo tutti
nella stessa barca appassioniamo ci
informiamo ci educhiamo i nostri figli
educhiamo i nostri anziani ad usare
quest'arma proprio perché se è vero poi
che la tecnologia porta innovazione
in realtà per il vero cambiamento per la
rivoluzione dobbiamo passare per forza
attraverso all'educazione
con questo vi ringrazio per ora